ما
[Silence]
د
مصفى الله اكبر الله اكبر اشهد ان لا اله
الا الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول الله حي على
الصلاه حي على الفلاح قد قامت الصلاه قد
قامت الصلاه
الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله ان شاء
[Silence]
الله استقيموا ترص واعتدلوا يرحمكم
الله ولا قوه الا بالله العلي
العظيم
الله
اكبر
الصلاه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد وا اياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قال الملا الذين استكبروا من قومه
لنخرجنك يا شعيب والذين امنوا معك من
قريتنا او
لتعودن في
ملتنا قال اولو كنا
كارهين قد افترينا على الله كذبا ان عدنا
في
ملتكم بعد اذ نجانا الله
منها لا يكون لنا ان نعود فيها الا ان
يشاء الله
ربنا وسع ربنا كل شيء علما على الله
توكلنا ربنا افتح بيننا وبين قومنا بالحق
وانت خير
الفاتحين وقال الملا الذين كفروا من قومه
لئن اتبعتم شعيبا انكم اذا
لخاسرون فاخذتهم الرجفه فاصبحوا في دارهم
جاثمين الذين كذبوا
شعيبا كان لم يغنوا
فيها الذين كذبوا شعيبا كانوا هم
الخاسرين فتولى عنهم قال يا قوم لقد
ابلغتكم رسالات ربي ونصحت لكم ونصحت لكم
فكيف اسى على قوم
كافرين وما ارسلنا في قريه من نبي الا
اخذنا اهلها
بالباساء
والضراء لعلهم
يضرعون
ثم بدلنا مكان السيئه الحسنه حتى عفوا
وقالوا قد مس
اباءنا
الضرا
والسراء
فاخذناهم بغته وهم لا
يشعرون ولو ان اهل القرى امنوا واتقوا
لفتحنا عن عليه
بركات من
السماء والارض ولكن
كذبوا ولكن كذبوا
فاخذناهم بما كانوا
يكسبون افامن اهل القرى ان
ياتيهم باسنا بياتا وهم
نائمون اومن اهل القرى ان ي يهم باسنا ضحى
وهم
يلعبون افامنوا مكر
الله فلا يامن مكر الله الا القوم
الخاسرون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين تلك القران قص عليك من
انباء اولم يهد للذين يرثون الارض من بعد
اهلها لو
نشاء اصبناهم بذنوبهم ونطبع على
قلوبهم ونطبع على قلوبهم فهم لا
يسمعون تلك القران قص عليك من
انباء ولقد
جاءتهم رسلهم بالبينات فما كانوا ليؤمنوا
بما كذبوا من قبل
كذلك يطبع الله على قلوب
الكافرين وما وجدنا لاكثرهم من عهد وان
وجدنا اكثرهم
لفاسقين ثم بعثنا من بعدهم موسى باياتنا
الى فرعون وملاه فظلموا بها فانظر كيف كان
عاقبه المفسد
وقال موسى يا فرعون اني رسول من رب
العالمين حقيق على الا اقول على الله الا
الحق قد جئتكم ببينه من ربكم فارسل معي
بني
اسرائيل قال ان كنت جئت بايه
فات بها ان كنت من
الصادقين فالقى عصاه فاذا هي
ثعبان
مبين ونزع يده فاذا هي
بيضاء
للناظرين قال الملا من قوم فرعون ان هذا
لساحر عليم يريد ان يخرجكم من ارضكم بسحره
فماذا
تامرون
ق يريد ان يخرجكم من ارضكم فماذا
تامرون قالوا ارجه واخاه وارسل في
المدائن
حاشرين ياتوك بكل ساحر
عليم
وجاء السحره فرعون قالوا ان لنا لاجرا ان
كنا نحن
الغالبين قال نعم وانكم لمن
المقربين قالوا يا موسى اما ان تلقي واما
ان نكون نحن
الملقين قال القوا فلما القوا سحروا اعين
الناس واسترهبوهم
جاءوا بسحر
عظيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد الرحمن
الرحيم مك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين ادنا الصرا
المستق
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
ال
الرحيم
نستعين صراط الذين انعمت
عليه
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
‏mer
[Silence]
‏a
س
صلاه الذين انعمت
[Silence]
علين مبارك
فيك
[Silence]
‏z
صلاه
القيام استقيم
واستو
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واوحينا الى موسى ان الق عصاك فاذا
هي تلقف ما
يافكون فوقع الحق وبطل ما كانوا
يعملون فغلبوا هنالك
وانقلبوا
صاغرين والقي السحره ساجدين قالوا امنا
برب العالمين رب موسى
وهارون قال فرعون
امنتم به قبل ان اذن لكم ان هذا لمكر
مكرتموه في المدينه لتخرجوا منها اهلها
فلسوف تعلمون
لاقطعن ايديكم وارجلكم من خلاف ثم
لاصلبنكم
اجمعين قالوا انا الى ربنا لم قالوا انا
الى ربنا
منقلبون وما تنقم منا الا ان امنا بايات
ربنا لما
جاءتنا
ربنا افرغ علينا صبرا وتوفنا
مسلمين وقال الملا من قوم فرعون اتذر موسى
وقومه ليفسدوا في الارض ويذرك
والهتك قال سنقتل
ابناءهم ونستحيي
نساءهم وانا فوقهم
قاهرون قال موسى لقومه استعينوا بالله
واصبروا ان الارض لله يورثها من
يشاء من عباده والعاقبه
للمتقين قالوا اوذينا من قبل ان تاتينا
ومن بعد ما
جئتنا قال عسى ربكم ان يهلك عدوكم
يستخلفكم في الارض فينظر كيف
تعملون ولقد اخذنا ال فرعون بالسنين ونقص
من الثمرات
لعلهم
يتذكرون لعلهم
يذكرون فاذا
جاءتهم الحسنه قالوا لنا
هذه وان تصبهم سيئه يطيروا بموسى ومن معه
الا انما
طائرهم عند الله ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون وقالوا مهما تاتنا به من ايه
لتسحرنا بها فما نحن لك
بمؤمنين فارسلنا عليهم الطوفان والجراد
والقمل الضفادع
والدم ايات
مفصلات فاستكبروا وكانوا قوما
مجرمين ولما وطع عليهم الرجز قالوا يا
موسى ادع لنا ربك بما عهد عندك لئن كشفت
عنا الرجز
لنؤمنن لك لنؤمنن لك ولنر سلن معك بني
اسرا
ئيل فلما كشفنا عنهم الرجز الى اجل هم
بالغوه اذا هم
ينكثون
فانتقمنا منهم
فاغرقناهم في اليم بانهم كذبوا
باياتنا وكانوا عنها
فانتقمنا منهم
فاغرقناهم في اليم بانهم كذبوا
باياتنا وكانوا عنها
معرضين وكانوا عنها غافلين واورثنا القوم
الذين كانوا يستضعفون مشارق الارض
ومغاربها التي باركنا فيها
وتمت كلمه ربك الحسنى على بني
اسرائيل بما
صبروا ودمرنا ما كان يصنع فرعون وقومه وما
كانوا
يعرشون وجاوزنا ببني
اسرائيل البحر فاتوا على قوم
يعكفون فاتوا على قوم يعكفون على اصنام
لهم قالوا يا موسى اجعل لنا الها كما لهم
الهه
قال انكم قوم
تجهلون ان
هؤلاء متبر ما هم فيه وباطل ما كانوا
يعملون قال اغير الله ابغيكم الها وهو
فضلكم على
العالمين واذ
انجيناكم من ال فرعون يصومون
سوء
العذاب يسومونكم سوء العذاب يقتلون
ابناءكم ويستحيون
نساءكم وفي ذلكم
بلاء من ربكم
عظيم الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وواعدنا موسى ثلاثين
ليله واتممناها
بعشر فتم ميقات ربه اربعين ليله وقال موسى
لاخيه هارون اخلفني في قومي واصلح ولا
تتبع سبيل
المفسدين ولما
جاء موسى
لميقاتنا وكلمه ربه قال رب ارني انظر
اليك قال لن تراني
ولكن انظر الى الجبل فان استقر مكانه فسوف
تراني فلما تجلا ربه للجبل جعله دكا وخر
موسى
صعقا فلما افاق قال سبحانك تبت اليك وانا
اول
المؤمنين قال يا موسى اني اصطفيتك على
الناس برس
تي وبكلامي فخذ ما اتيتك وكن من
الشاكرين وكتبنا له في الالواح من كل شيء
موعظه وتفصيلا لكل
شيء فخذها بقوه وامر قومك ياخذوا باحسنها
ساريكم دار
الفاسقين ساصرف عن اي الذين يتكبرون في
الارض بغير الحق وان يروا كل ايه لا
يؤمنوا بها وان يروا سبيل الرشد لا يتخذوه
سبيلا وان يروا سبيل الغي يتخذوه سبيلا
ذلك بانهم كذبوا
باياتنا وكانوا عنها
غافلين والذي كذبوا باياتنا
ولقاء الاخره حبطت
اعمالهم هل يجزون الا ما كانوا يعملون
واتخذ قوم موسى من بعده من حليهم عجلا
جسدا له
خوار الم يروا انه لا يكلمهم ولا يهديهم
سبيلا اتخذوا وكانوا
ظالمين ولما سقط في ايديهم وراوا انهم قد
ضلوا قالوا لئن لم يرحمنا ربنا ويغفر لنا
لنكونن من
الخاسرين ولما رجع موسى الى قومه غضبان
اسفا قال بئس ما خلفتموني من بعدي اعجلتم
امر ربكم والقى الالواح واخذ براس اخيه
يجره
اليه قال ابن ام ان القوم استضعفوني
وكادوا يقتلونني فلا تشمت بي
الاعداء ولا تجعلني مع القوم
الظالمين ولما سكت عن موسى الغضب اخذ
الالواح وفي نسختها هدى ورحمه للذين هم
لربهم
يرهبون قال رب اغفر لي ولاخي وادخلنا في
رحمتك وانت ارحم
الراحمين ان الذين اتخذوا العجل سينالهم
غضب من ربهم وذله في الحياه
الدنيا وكذلك نجزي الم ترين والذين عملوا
السيئات ثم تابوا من بعدها وامنوا ان ربك
من بعدها لغفور
رحيم ولما سكت عن موسى الغضب اخذ الالواح
وفي نسختها هدى ورحمه للذين هم لربهم
يرهبون واختار موسى قومه سبعين رجلا
لميقاتنا فلما اخذتهم الرجفه قال رب لو
شئت
اهلكتهم من قبل
واياي اتهلكنا بما فعل
السفهاء
منا ان هي الا فتنتك تضل بها من
تشاء وتهدي من
تشاء
انت ولينا فاغفر لنا وارحمنا وانت خير
الغافلين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين اهدنا
الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
واكتب لنا في هذه الدنيا
حسنه وفي الاخره انا هدنا
اليك قال عذابي اصيب به من
اشاء ورحمتي وسعت كل
شيء فساكتبها
للذين يتقون ويؤتون الزكاه والذين هم
اياتنا
يؤمنون الذين يتبعون الرسول النبي
الامي الذي يجدونه مكتوبا عندهم في
التوراه
والانجيل يامرهم بالمعروف وينهاهم عن
المنكر ويحل لهم الطيبات ويحرم عليهم
الخبا ئث ويضع عنهم اصرهم والاغلال التي
كانت
عليهم فالذين امنوا به وعزروه ونصروه
واتبعوا النور الذي انزل معه
اولئك هم
المفلحون قل يا ايها الناس اني رسول الله
اليكم جميعا الذي له ملك السماوات والارض
لا اله الا هو يحيي
ويميت فامنوا بالله ورسوله النبي الامي
الذي يؤمن بالله
وكلماته واتبعوه لعلكم
تهتدون ومن قوم موسى امه يهدون بالحق وبه
يعدلون
وقطعناهم اثنتي عشره اسباطا امما واوحينا
الى موسى اذ استسقاه قومه ان اضرب بعصاك
الحجر فانبجست منه اثنتا عشره
عينا قد علم كل اناس
مشربهم وظللنا عليهم الغمام وانزلنا عليهم
المن
والسلوى كلوا من طيبات ما رزقناكم وما
ظلمونا ولكن كانوا
انفسهم
يظلمون واذ قيل لهم اسكنوا هذه القريه
وكلوا منها حيث شئتم وقولوا حطه وادخلوا
الباب سجدا نغفر لكم خ
بيئتكم سنزيد
المحسنين فبدل الذين ظلموا منهم قولا غير
الذي قيل لهم فارسلنا عليهم رجزا من
السماء بما كانوا
يظلمون واسالهم عن القريه التي كانت حاضره
البحر اذ يعدون في السبت اذ تاتيهم ح تهم
يوم سبتهم
شرعا ويوم لا يسبتون لا
تاتيهم كذلك نبلوهم بما كانوا
يفسقون واذ قالت امه منهم لم تعظون قوما
الله مهلكهم او معذبهم عذابا
شديدا قالوا معذره الى ربكم ولعلهم
يتقون فلما نسوا ما ذكروا به انجينا الذين
ينهون عن
السوء واخذنا الذين ظلموا بعذاب بئيس بما
كانوا
يفسقون فلما عتوا
عمانه عنه قلنا لهم كونوا قرده
خاسئين واذ تاذن ربك
ليبعثن عليهم الى يوم القيامه من يسومهم
سوء
العذاب ان ربك لسريع العقاب وانه لغفور
الرحيم
وقطعناهم في الارض امما منهم الصالحون
ومنهم دون ذلك
وبلوناهم بالحسنات والس سيئات لعلهم
يرجعون فخلف من بعدهم خلف ورثوا الكتاب
ياخذون عرض هذا الادنى ويقولون سيغفر لنا
وان ياتهم عرض مثله
ياخذوه الم يؤخذ عليهم ميثاق الكتاب الا
يقولوا على الله الا الحق ودرسوا ما فيه
والدار الاخره خير للذين
يتقون افلا
تعقلون والذين يمسكون بالكتاب واقاموا
الصلاه انا لا نضيع اجر
المصلحين الله
اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واذ نتقنا الجبل فوقهم كانه ظله
وظنوا انه واقع بهم خذوا ما
اتيناكم بقوه واذكروا ما فيه لعلكم
تتقون واذ اخذ ربك من بني ادم من ظهورهم
ذريتهم واشهدهم على انفسهم الست
بربكم قالوا بلى شهدنا ان تقولوا يوم
القيامه انا كنا عن هذا
غافلين او تقولوا انما اشرك
اباؤنا من قبل وكنا
ذريه من بعدهم
افتهلكنا بما فعل
المبطلون وكذلك نفصل الايات ولعلهم يرجعون
واتل عليهم نبا الذي اتيناه اياتنا فانسلخ
منها فاتبع الشيطان فكان من
الغاوين ولو شئنا لرفعناه بها
ولكنه اخلد الى الارض واتبع
هواه فمثله كمثل الكلب ان تحمل عليه يلهث
او تتركه يث ذلك مثل القوم الذين كذبوا
باياتنا فاقصص القصص لعلهم
يتفكرون
ساء مثلا القوم الذين كذبوا باياتنا
وانفسهم كانوا
يظلمون من يهدي الله فهو المهتدي ومن يضلل
فاولئك هم الخاسرون ولقد ذرانا لجهنم
كثيرا من الجن والانس لهم قلوب لا يفقهون
بها ولهم اعين لا يبصرون بها ولهم اذان لا
يسمعون بها
اولئك كالانعام بل هم اضل
اولئك هم
الخاسرون اولئك هم
الغافلون ولله الاسماء الحسنى فادعو بها
وذروا الذين يلحدون في
اسمائه سيجزون ما كانوا
يعملون وممن خلقنا امه يهدون بالحق وبه
يعدلون والذين كذبوا باياتنا سنستدرجهم من
حيث لا يعلمون واملي لهم ان كيدي متين
اولم
يتفكروا ما
بصاحبهم من
جه ان هو الا نذير مبين اولم ينظروا في
ملكوت السماوات والارض وما خلق الله من
شيء وان عسى ان يكون قد اقترب اجلهم فباي
حديث بعده
يؤمنون من يضلل الله فلا هادي له ويذرهم
في طغيانهم
يعمهون يسالونك عن الساعه ايان
مرساها قل انما علمها عند ربي لا يجليها
لوقتها الا هو ثقلت في السماوات والارض لا
تاتيكم الا بغته يسالونك كانك حفي عنها قل
انما علمها عند الله ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يعلمون قل لا املك لنفسي نفعا ولا ضرا الا
ما
شاء
الله ولو كنت اعلم الغيب لاستكثرت من
الخير وما مسني
السوء وما مسني
السوء ان انا الا نذير وبشير
لقوم
يؤمنون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر
اكبر الله
الله اكبر ‏kom
[Silence]
l
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
‏m
‏det
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الصلاه والسلام على رسول الله وعلى
وصحبه ومنه ومن تبح الدين الل صل وسم وك
محد وعلى اله
وح ايمن
ض
مد
[Silence]
عبول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏tr nobody family does not any siblings
does not sister his father
[Silence]
married
tak
[Silence]
رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم عبد
المطلب
‏ail all
incept رسول الله
علم
رول الله صلى الله عليه
[Silence]
وسلم
الله
علي رض عن
عل
ابول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
صل
عليه عليه
[Silence]
الصلام
‏take
[Silence]
ان شا الله سبحانه
وتالى رسول الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم
[Silence]
اللهه
اللهصلى
[Silence]
علمول
ربنا اتنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا
عذاب جنم وقنا عذا فتنه محمات وقنا عذاب
فتنه مسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منا انك انت
السميع العليم وتب علينا يا م التواب
الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد وعلى اله وصحبه
اجمعين برحتك ارحم الراحمين اللهم امين
اللهم امين اللهم امين
[Silence]
استقيموا اعتدلوا
استووا سدوا الخلل
لا ان شاء الله سجده تلاوه سجده سك
ركعه
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط راط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين هو الذي خلقكم من نفس واحده وجعل
منها زوج
وجعل منها زوجها ليسكن
اليها فلما تغشاها حملت حملا حملا خفيفا
فمرت
به فلما اثقلت دعو الله ربهما لئن اتيتنا
صالحا لئن اتيتنا صالحا
لنكونن من الشاك
فلما اتاهما صالحا جعلا له
شركاء فيما
اتاهما فتعالى الله
عما
يشركون ايشركون ما لا يخلق
شيئا ايشركون ما لا يخلق
شيئا وهم يخلقون
ولا
يستطيعون لهم نصرا ولا انفسهم
ينصرون
وان تدعوهم الى الهدى لا
يتبعوكم
سواء عليكم ادعوتموهم ام انتم
صامتون
ان الذين تدعون من دون الله عباد
امثالكم فادعوهم
فليستجيبوا
لكم فادعوهم
فليستجيبوا لكم ان
كنتم
صادقين الهم الهم
ارجل يمشون بها ام لهم
ايدي يبطشون
بها
ام لهم اعين يبصرون بها ام لهم اذان
يسمعون بها قل ادعوا
شهداءكم
ثم
كيدون قل ادعوا
شهداءكم من دون الله ثم كيدون فلا
تنظرون
قل فادعوا
شركاءكم
ثم كيدون فلا
تنظرون ان ولي الله الذي نزل الكتاب وهو
يتولى
الصالحين والذين تدعون من دونه لا يسمعوا
دعاءكم والذين تدعون من دونه لا يستطيعون
نصركم لا يستطيعون نصركم ولا انفسهم
ينصرون وان تدعوهم لا
يسمعوه وان تدعوهم لا
يسمعوه
وان تدعوهم الى الهدى لا
يسمعوا وتراهم
ينظرون اليك وهم
يبصرون وتراهم ينظرون اليك وهم لا
يبصرون خذ العفو وامر بالعرف واعرض عن
الجاهلين واما
ينزغنك من الشيطان نزغ فاستعذ
بالله فاستعذ بال ل
انه سميع
عليم ان الذين اتقوا اذا مسهم
طائف من الشيطان
تذكروا تذكروا فاذا
هم
مبصرون واخوانهم
يمدونهم في الغي ثم لا
يقصرون واخوانهم يمدونهم في
الغي
ثم لا
يقصرون واذا لم تاتهم
بايه قالوا لولا اجتبيتها
قل انما اتبع ما يوحى الي من
ربي هذا
بصائر من ربكم وهدى
ورحمه
وهدى ورحمه
لقوم
يؤمنون
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اك
الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين واذا قرئ القران فاستمعوا له
وانصتوا لعلكم
ترحمون واذكر ربك في نفسك تضرعا
وخيفه ومن القول بالغ ودون الجهر من القول
بالغدو والاص
ولا
تكن من
الغافلين ان الذين عند ربك
يسبحونه ان الذين عند ربك لا يستكبرون عن
عباد ان الذين عند ربك لا
يستكبرون عن
عبادته
يسبحونه
ويسبحونه وله
يسجدون
الله
اكبر يسالونك عن ان فال قل الثال لله
والرسول فاتقوا الله واصلحوا ذات بينكم
واطيعوا الله ورسوله ان كنتم
مؤمنين انما المؤمنون الذين اذا ذكر الله
وجلت
قلوبهم واذا تليت عليهم اياته زادتهم
ايمانا وعلى ربهم
يتوكلون الذين يقيمون الصلاه ومما
رزقناهم
ينفقون
اولئك هم المؤمنون
حقا لهم درجات عند ربهم
ومغفره ورزق
كريم كما اخرجك ربك من بيتك بالحق وان
فريقا من المؤمنين
لكارهون يسارع
وان وان فريقا من المؤمنين
لكارهون
يجادلونك في الحق بعدما تبين
لهم
يجادلونك في الحق بعد ما تبين
كانما يساقون الى الموت وهم
ينظرون واذ يعدكم الله احدى
الطائفتين انها
لكم وتودون ان غير ذات الشوكه تكون لكم
ويريد الله ان يحق الحق
بكلماته ويق قطع دابر
الكافرين ليحق الحق ويبطل الباطل ولو كره
المجرمون اذ
تستغيثون ربكم فاستجاب لكم اني
ممدكم اني
ممدكم بالف من
الملائكه مردفين
وما جعله الله
الا بشرى ولتطمئن
به
قلوبكم وما نصر الا من عند الله ان الله
عزيز حكيم اذ يغشيكم النعاس
امنه منه وينزل
عليكم وينزل عليكم من
السماء ما
ليطهركم به ويذهب عنكم رجز الشيطان وليربط
على
قلوبكم وليربط على قلوبكم ويثبت به
الاقدام اذ يوحي ربك الى
الملائكه اني معكم
اني معكم فثبتوا الذين
امنوا سالقي في قلوب الذين كفروا الرعب
فاضربوا فوق
الاعناق فاضربوا فوق الاعناق واضربوا منهم
كل
بنان ذلك
بانهم
شاقوا الله
ورسوله ومن يشاقق الله ورسوله
فان الله شديد
العذاب ذلكم فذوقوه
وان
للكافرين عذاب
النار يا ايها الذين امنوا اذا لقيتم
الذين كفروا زحفا فلا تولوهم
الادبار ومن يولهم
يومئذ دبره الا
متحرفا الا متحرفا لقتال او متحيزا الى
فئه فقد
باء فقد
باء
بغضب من
الله ماواه
جهنم وبئس
المصير
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكب
الله
اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فلم تقتلوهم
ولكن الله
قتلهم وما رميت اذ رميت
ولكن الله رمى وليبلي المؤمنين منه بلاء
حسنا ان الله سميع عليم ذلكم وان الله
موهن كيد
الكافرين ان تستفتحوا فقد
جاءكم الفتح
وان تنتهوا فهو خير لكم وان تعودون عد ولن
تغني عنكم فئتكم شيئا ولو
كثرت
وان الله مع
المؤمنين يا ايها الذين امنوا اطيعوا الله
ورسوله ولا تولوا عنه وانتم
تسمعون ولا تكونوا كالذين قالوا سمعنا وهم
لا
يسمعون ان شر
الدوا
ب عند الله الصم البكم الذين لا
يعقلون ولو علم الله فيهم خيرا
لاسمعهم ولو اسمعهم لتولوا وهم
معرضون يا ايها الذين امنوا استجيبوا لله
وللرسول اذا
دعاكم استجيبوا لله
وللرسول اذا دعاكم لما يحييكم
واعلموا واعلموا ان الله يحول بين المرء
وقلبه
وانه اليه
تحشرون واتقوا فتنه لا
تصيبن الذين ظلموا منكم
خاصه واتقوا فتنه
لا
تصيبن الذين ظلموا منكم
خاصه واعلموا ان الله شديد
العقاب واذكروا اذ انتم قليل مستضعفون في
الارض تخافون ان
يتخطفكم الناس
فاوا فاوا
وايدكم بنصره
ورزقكم من
الطيبات
ورزقكم من الطيبات لعلكم
تشكرون يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تخونوا
الله والرسول وتخونوا
امانكم وتخونوا
امانكم وانتم
تعلمون علموا انما اموالكم
واولادكم
فتنه
وان الله
عنده اجر
عظيم يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تتقوا الله
يجعل لكم
فرقانا يجعل لكم فرقانا ويكفر عنكم
سيئاتكم
والله ذو الفضل
العظيم سمع الله لمن
حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا ان تتقوا الله
يجعل لكم
فرقانا ويكفر
عنكم يجعل لكم فرقانا ويكفر عنكم ذن من
سيئاتكم ويغفر
لكم يكفر عنكم سيئاتكم ويغفر لكم والله ذو
الفضل العظيم واذ يمكر بك الذين كفروا واذ
يمكر بك الذين كفروا ليخرجوا ليثبتوك
ليثبتوك او يقتلوك او
يخرجوك ويمكرون ويمكر الله والله خير
الماكرين
واذا تتلى عليهم اياتنا قالوا قد سمعنا
مثل هذا قالوا قد سمعنا لو
نشاء لقلنا مثل
هذا قالوا قد سمعنا لو
نشاء لقلنا مثل هذا ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين واذ قالوا اللهم ان كان هذا هو
الحق من
عندك فامطر علينا
حجاره من
السماء او ائتنا بعذاب اليم وما كان الله
ليعذبهم وانت فيهم وما كان الله معذبهم
وهم
يستغفرون
وما لهم الا يعذبهم الله وهم يصدون عن
المسجد الحرام وما كانوا
اولياءه ان
اولياءه الا
المتقون ان
اولياؤه الا المتقون ولكن اكثرهم لا
يعلمون
وما كان صلاتهم عند البيت الا
مكاء
وتصديه فذوقوا العذاب بما كنتم
تكفرون ان الذين كفروا يصدوا ان الذين
كفروا
ينفقون اموالهم ليصدوا عن سبيل الله
فسينفقونها
ثم تكون عليهم حسره
ثم
يغلبون والذين كفروا الى جهنم
يحشرون ليميز الله الخبيث من الطيب ويجعل
الخبيث ويجعل الخبيث بعضه على
بعض
فيركمه
جميعا فيركمه
جميعا فيجعله في
جهنم فيجعله في
جهنم
اولئك هم
الخاسرون قل للذين كفروا ان ينتهوا يغفر
لهم ما قد سلف وان يعودوا فقد مضت
سه
الاولين
وقاتلوهم حتى لا تكون
فتنه
وقاتلوهم حتى لا تكون فتنه ويكون الدين
كله
لله فان
انتهوا
فان الله بما يعملون بصير
وان تولوا
فاعلموه
وان تولوا فاعلموا
انما الله
مولاكم وان تولوا فاعلموا ان الله
مولاكم نعم المولى ونعم
النصير
الله سمع الله لمن
[Silence]
حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله
[Silence]
ا
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه
[Silence]
الله
صلاه الوتر ان شاء
اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
ويل لكل همزه لمزه الذي جمع
مالا
وعدده يحسب ان
ماله
اخلده كلا
لينبذن
في
الحطمه
وما ادراك ما
الحطمه نار الله
الموقده التي تطلع على
الافئده
انها
عليهم
مؤصده في
عمد
ممدده سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم
الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
ضالين
امين اذا جاء نصر الله
والفتح ورايت الناس يدخلون في دين الله
افواجا فسبح بحمد ربك
واستغفره
انه كان
توابا
الله سمع الله لمن
[Silence]
حمده
الله
اكبر بسم الله الحمد لله رب العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب
عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد
سمع الله لمن حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا
كثيرا طيبا مباركا فيه كما تحب
وترضا اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في
من عافيت وتولنا فيم توليت وبارك لنا فيما
اعطيت واصرف عنا ب رحمتك شر ما قدرت وقضيت
انك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك انه لا يذل
من واليت ولا يعز من عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم لا منجا ولا ملجى منك الا
اليك نستغفرك ربنا من جميع الذنوب
والخطايا ونتوب
والخطايا ونتوب اليك اللهم تقبل
صيامنا
وصلاتنا
وقيامنا
وقراننا وصالح
اعمالنا اللهم اجعله خالصا اللهم انا
نسالك الفردوس وما قرب اليها من قول او
عمل ونعوذ بك من النار وما قرب اليها من
قول او
عمل اللهم اصلح لنا ديننا الذي هو عصمه
امرنا واصلح لنا دنيانا التي فيها معاشنا
واصلح لنا اخرتنا التي اليها معادنا اللهم
واجعل الحياه الدنيا زياده لنا في كل خير
والموت راحه لنا من كل
شر اللهم واجرنا من خزي الدنيا وعذاب
الاخره برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم اعز
الاسلام والمسلمين واعلي وانصر كلمتي الحق
والدين المبين وانصر اخواننا المستضعفين
من المسلمين في كل
مكان اللهم انصرهم على عدوك
وعدوهم فانهم لا يعجزونك يا قوي يا عزيز
اللهم عليك
بالظالمين اللهم عليك
بالظالمين ونج
المسلمين في غزه
وفلسطين اللهم برحمتك كلهم معينا
ونصيرا اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على سيدنا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
والتابعين اللهم وارضى عنا وعنهم
اجمعين سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون
وسلام على المرسلين والحمد لله رب
العالمين الله
اكبر
الله
اكب
[Silence]
اكبر
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
[Silence]
ا
ان